[Musik]
impfschädenustrialisierung und Krieg
viel zu besprechen heute Abend bei
viertel nach acht mit diesen Gästen
Psycho neuroimmunologe christian
Schubert von der Universität Innsbruck
er ist Corona Kritiker der ersten Stunde
und warnt jetzt extrem vor den
Nebenwirkungen der Impfung Medienmanager
Hans marblick auf den Krieg in der
Ukraine ihn beschäftigen heute Abend vor
allem die Kosten ZDF Urgestein und
Publizist Wolfgang Herles hadert mit der
grünen Partei und sieht unseren
Wohlstand in Gefahr ex-regierung
Sprecher Bela under haartet hingegen mit
der deutschen Verbotspolitik Deutschland
spricht heute Abend vor allem auch über
die flüchtlingskrise und die immer
dramatischen Folgen und das ist heute
die Schlagzeile des Tages die Kommunen
können nicht mehr Bürgermeister schlagen
Alarm CDU-Politiker christian beidorf
hat seinen er seinen Ärger bei der
richtigen Fragen Luft gemacht werden wir
doch einmal rein
man muss dieses Asylrecht überdenken das
glaube ich schon und zwar natürlich sehr
human sie müssen am Ende des Tages
schauen dass sie hier keine Anreize
bieten und dann will ich Ihnen einen
Punkt auch noch nennen wieso zahlen wir
denn Gelder an alle diejenigen die
herkommen da würden natural Leistungen
zunächst auch mal reichen
Naturalleistung so deutlich hat es kaum
ein Politiker je ausgesprochen kein Geld
mehr für Flüchtlinge ist das die Lösung
Hans
ich glaube in dem Fall kann man das
nicht so allgemein sehen aber ich bin
viel eher der Meinung dass deutschen
Justizministers der gesagt hat die
Einbürgerung die dafür aus der folgen
wenn jemand auch einen Job hat denn dass
wir nur auf die Dauer mit Leistungen
prahlen und alle alle alle Geld
ausschütten ohne dass die Menschen auch
einfinden in die in die in die Arbeit
das geht auf die Dauer nicht ich glaube
da müssen wir ein bisschen härter werden
das hat nichts zu tun also mit mit
Herzlosigkeit sondern mit Vernunft denn
wir können auf die Dauer diesen Staaten
nicht erhalten wenn wir Millionen
Menschen aufnehmen die ungeregelt zu uns
kommen und die ungeregelt etwas Geld
bekommen dass alle Steuerzahler etwas
kostet
das ist richtig deshalb muss man da
besonders vorsichtig sein nicht dass es
geht natürlich nicht auf die Dauer dass
jemand und ich weiß dass aus eigenen
Bekanntenkreis dass jemand der Geld der
bezieht und zwar für Mutter zwei Kinder
und so weiter dann sagt arbeiten gehen
ich weiß nicht ob das sinnvoll ist ja
weil ich bekomme dann weniger als ich
bekomme wenn ich die ganzen die ganzen
fürsorgen und die ganzen Betreuungen
kassiere das geht nicht und da muss man
Grenzen setzen da bin ich der Meinung
dass das überhaupt nicht herzlos ist
sondern dass das auch im Sinne der ist
dies betrifft nämlich damit die auch so
angesehen werden wie sie angesehen
werden wollen jemand der kommt als Gast
und hier Platz finden will und arbeiten
will und auch einen Teil der
Gemeinschaft sein wollen
sie von dem Vorschlag Sachleistung kein
Geld darüber kann man reden aber die
großen Probleme ist andere erstens wird
in Deutschland immer noch nicht
unterschieden zwischen denen die wir
brauchen weil wir Arbeitskräfte
Fachkräfte brauchen einander
und denen die in die Sozialsystem
Migranten pro Jahr qualifizierter ja
aber qualifizierte nicht die die kommen
um in die Sozialsysteme einzuwandern
wenn die kommen dann wird man sie ja
nicht mehr los das ist das eigentliche
Problem ja also wenn man es nicht
schafft mit den Abschiebungen wenn Sie
schon mal hier sind so ähnlich jetzt
glaube ich meine Frau Merkel gesagt das
sind sie halt da ja dann muss man sie
halt auch anständig behandeln das finde
ich schon was aber nicht geht ist dass
das auf Kosten der deutschen Bevölkerung
und zwar auch das sozial Schwachen
passiert wie es Geschehene sind Lörrach
werden sozialmieter
entmietet wie man so schön sagt in
Berlin wird ein Altenheim geschlossen
damit der Flüchtlinge einziehen das sind
alles Dinge die die Akzeptanz der
Flüchtlinge in diesem Land
zerstören und das ist überhaupt das
entscheidende dass die Leute hier
willkommen sind und wenn sie gekommen
sind dann müssen wir auch was tun dann
müssen Sie selber für Integration eine
Lösung dafür also wie uns dieser Anrei
ze zum Arbeiten gelingt wie wir schaffen
mehr Flüchtlingen Arbeit zu bringen
die dürfen wir zum Teil gar nicht
arbeiten selbst wenn sie es wollten das
ist ein Problem dass man auch nicht ganz
ausblenden darf aber das Problem ist
nicht zu lösen sie müssen weniger Leute
reinlassen sie müssen die wenn sie sich
nicht wollen schon an den an den Grenzen
müssen Sie die Sache regeln und wenn Sie
hier sind müssen sie die auch abschieben
können da ist das Problem
einen kalt in der Runde gehen wir mal zu
Bela ja wir sehen hier so ein
klassischen Mangel an politischer
Kommunikation denn wenn du sagst Nena
und einmal müssen wir dir gratulieren
also einmal zu 4bs Bräutigam Bild
Bestseller alte weise Männer freue ich
mich schon auf immer das Land wird aber
meine Voraussage ist unter den Top 10
und jetzt auch wieder Bild TV willkommen
zurück wir freuen uns sehr ich freue
mich auch wieder hier zu sein ganz klar
gibt's dafür Sekt heute oder
schmeckt nach Champagner das ist
eigentlich ein bisschen schade aber die
Themen sind auch zu ernst und
dementsprechend bleiben wir bei den
Flüchtlingen aber ich bedanke mich für
die Glückwünsche sehr gern aber noch mal
zurück zum Thema also diese politische
Kommunikation die hier völlig aus dem
Ruder gelaufen ist wenn du sagst Nena
400.000 werden gebraucht jedes Jahr und
das sind ja offizielle Zahlen jeden Tag
ne ich glaube der Mehrzahl der
Bevölkerung sagt 400.000 noch mehr
Menschen wo sollen die denn alle
unterkommen die kommunalen Amtsträger
die Bürgermeister die Landräte sagen die
sind schon voll wir sind Schulen
tonhallen die überfüllt sind mit
Flüchtlingen und das kommunale Leben was
natürlich darunter echt das ist eine
Wahrheit die kann man auch nicht weg
negieren und sagen das ist halt mal so
sondern die belastet viele Kommunen die
belastet viele Menschen und die wird ein
bisschen negiert dann gibt so ein
flüchtlingsgipfel ja da ist man sich so
ein bisschen einander einig und
natürlich hat die CDU gesehen dass die
dieses Thema den Menschen auf die Nägeln
brennt und deswegen veranstalten die ja
mit den
eigenen Leuten aus den Gemeinden einen
eigenen flüchtlingsgipfel und deswegen
gibt es auch solche Äußerungen aber alle
pauschal der über einen Kamm zu stehen
und sagen alle Flüchtlinge sind
natürlich jetzt ganz furchtbar das ist
es nicht sie müssen schnell den Arbeit
gebracht werden können das hat der
CDU-Politiker auch gar nicht gesagt er
hat nicht gesagt alle Flüchtlinge sind
furchtbar sondern hat gesagt er schlägt
vor Sachleistung anstatt Geld ja dann
muss die Zeit des flüchtlingsdaseins
aber auch begrenzt sein und begrenzt
sein können mit auch den Konsequenzen
dass wir es nicht schaffen dann eben
zurückgeführt wird oder zurückgeführt
werden kann oder meinetwegen in einen
europäischen Nachbarstaat aber nicht auf
Dauer hier eben alimentiert wird
deswegen hat er auch gesagt Asylgesetz
grundlegend ändern da sind wir hier alle
einer Meinung da ist natürlich dann die
Frage herrlich warum passiert das denn
nicht also hier ist selten so viel
Einigkeit am Tisch wie jetzt gerade was
das Thema Flüchtlinge betrifft
ändert sich ja gefühlt nichts und was
Sie gesagt haben stimmt auch manche
warten drei Jahre auf der
Arbeitserlaubnis weil dahinter eine
Ideologie steckt ja wir sind weltoffen
wir sind alle da wir haben ein großes
Herz es wird nicht rational entschieden
es ist
Gesinnungsethik und nicht
Verantwortungsethik wenn ich das mal
sagen darf ja es wird es wird nach einem
Prinzip entschieden das Moral das ist
moralistisch ist ich will nicht sagen
moralisch ist auch nicht unmoralisch
aber es ist moralistisch und damit kann
man keine Politik machen Entschuldigung
wir werden noch mehr unter Druck kommen
wenn die Engländer das tatsächlich wahr
machen dass sie jeden der nicht legal
einreißt sofort wieder zurückreißt dass
er gar nicht die Möglichkeit bekommt
mehr um einen Flüchtlingsstatus
anzusuchen dann würden wir noch mehr
unter Druck kommen weil dann werden die
Leute eben wieder ausweichen von England
natürlich mehr nach Deutschland weil das
das beliebteste ein landwanderungsland
ist und da braucht man wirklich einmal
konkrete politische Ansätze und nicht
nur immer ja wir werden schon irgendwo
schaffen
sie sind in Deutsch aber leben ja in
Österreich ich bin Österreicher und bin
in Deutschland aufgewachsen dann sind
sie beide sind wenigsten Österreicher
aber wie diskutiert man in Österreich
darüber
ich
gute Frage wie man Österreich
wahrscheinlich eh ähnlich wie hier ich
habe nur bei den ersten Statement immer
härtere Worte gefunden
nee was mir hier aufgefallen ist eine
Runde weil weil die Frage so für alle so
einer Meinung sind was ich hier gehört
habe ist wir haben es immer mit Menschen
zu tun als erster Stelle die hierher
kommen und und vielen so Worte wie wenn
sie kommen dann werden wir sie nicht
mehr los oder 400.000 werden gebraucht
ich habe für was werden die gebraucht
werden die missbraucht weil man sie
braucht was für unseren Wohlstand wir
warum weiß ich ich höre hier ja mir
fehlt das ja klar bei mir fehlt hier
zunächst mal dass es sich um Menschen
handelt und diese Menschen kommen aus
Ländern wo es offensichtlich nicht so
schön ist wie bei uns die müssen
flüchten aus welchen Gründen auch immer
und sind mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit
traumatisiert und wenn wir uns diese
Menschen ins Land hereinholen und sie
gleich mal in die Arbeit schicken ja ich
weiß es dass meine psychotherapeutischen
tra realisiert sind verängstigt sind
depressiv sind psychopathologisch
auffällig sind dann brauche ich die
nicht gleich in die arbeitsverstecken ja
und und sie zu überfordern die werden
zuerst mal die müssen das mal abgeholt
werden und wenn ich die Probleme wenn
wir solche Leute die Menschen sind um
Gottes Willen selbstverständlich aber
wenn wir so traumatisierte Personen
anziehen dann wird es ja für uns auch
ein Problem genauso ist es ja genauso
ist es genau das will ich damit sagen
also ich würde sagen wir müssen diese
Menschen zunächst mal menschlich abholen
das heißt das allererste was einzelne
wahrnehmen ne wir müssen Sie als
einzelne will arbeiten und darf nicht
und der andere glaubt er muss arbeiten
und kann nicht immer das ist der da
kommt oder welche Möglichkeiten diese
Person überhaupt mitbringen arbeiten zu
können auf jeden Fall eine Obergrenze
weil wenn man beispielsweise ein Haus
nimmt in ein Haus passen ja auch nicht
100 Leute rein sondern vielleicht nur
zehn Leute sehr gut leben können das
heißt wie wollen wir schaffen wenn immer
mehr Menschen kommen es wird ja jetzt
schon zu wenig auf den einzelnen
geschaut ich habe meine Kamera im
Flüchtlingsheim gearbeitet da kann ich
sagen er wird auf angeschaut ganz
furchtbar das heißt genau das meine ich
für die Flüchtlinge besser wenn man sagt
es werden nur so und so viele
aufgenommen aber die werden richtig
integriert warum werden denn nur so
wenig dann aufgenommen Frage aber wenig
aber sagen wir mal jetzt ja zu wenig
Geld oder wie immer in den letzten drei
Jahren haben wir doch Geld ausgepfeffert
was das Zeug hält für alles mögliche und
jetzt plötzlich fehlt Geld sorry
ein bisschen zu einfach ich meinte
appellieren hier an den Menschenverstand
und wer könnte dem ich fand das ja nicht
verstanden sondern Menschlichkeit wer
könnte dem etwas entgegensetzen wenn wir
nicht alle Menschen Feindes sein wollen
dass keiner von uns sein wird fakt ist
doch das was wir alle wissen dass die
Kommunen echt sind unter den Belastungen
man muss es einfach so nennen von
Menschen die zu uns gekommen sind wo die
Kommunen sich aber alle eingelassen
fühlen also die verschiedenen Landkreise
die Städte die kein Platz haben wo die
Schulen überqu ich keine Lehrkräfte
haben für diese Menschen die
unentwegt und immer weiter zu uns kommt
wo es kein stoppen gibt und auch keine
Integration in die Maße wie wir es
eigentlich haben müssten kein
Deutschland in dem Maße deswegen sind
wir doch nicht Menschenfeinde wenn wir
einfach darauf hinweisen es ist diese
Zustände gibt und uns mit den Fragen
beschäftigen was kann man tun um diesen
Zustand zu ändern und sie sagen lasst
ein fröhlich weil das Geld ist ja da
muss auch dafür ausgegeben es kann
Methode mit diesem Problem aber nicht
gesagt dass hier Menschen fahren gesagt
das allererste was ich hier für mich als
Mensch verlange ist Menschlichkeit
diesen diesen Einwanderern und
Flüchtlingen gegenüber und das ist
kurzfristig und linear gedacht zu sagen
wir holen Sie jetzt
Arbeit für mich ist es ein nachhaltiges
Thema die werden eben nicht gehen
sondern sie werden sich hier integrieren
was ich hoffe Sie werden sich an die
Kultur anpassen sie werden hier leben
sie werden hier Familie gründen und das
heißt wir werden nachhaltig für diese
Menschen sorgen müssen so dass wir nicht
eine weiterhin Angst erkrankte
Gesellschaft haben weil genau das ist ja
gerade das große Thema und Problem indem
wir uns befinden wir haben wahnsinnig
viel kranke Menschen in diesem Land aber
das sind in Länder aber die Angst der
krankung das kann ja auch in Grund dafür
sein dass wir zu viele neue Bürger
Aufnehmer oder Flüchtlinge aufnehmen
immer noch das kann zu Angst
Erkrankungen führen wenn Sie heute auf
einen Bahnhof bringen können wo ich zu
Hause bin da denken Sie nicht das in
Deutschland sind ja das ist jetzt nichts
Böses man darf das ja auch nicht
aussprechen ist mir egal AFD oder sonst
irgendwas
auszusprechen weil ich es weiß von
meinem Bekannten und Freunden und vor
allem von Frauen ja die sagen ja das
geht so nicht also man darf die Angst
den nicht immer sehen nur der einen
Seite einwandererseite
auch die in ganz bewandert von denen die
von der Einwanderung betroffen sind da
muss man das auch sehen absolut sehe ich
auch aber dann wie gesagt dann kümmern
wir uns bitte um diese Menschen die hier
in unser Land kommen um deren
angstprobleme damit wir selber keine
Angst haben müssen irgendwann mal das
ist die Messen
jeder hier in der Runde und jetzt kommen
wir zu einem anderen Thema und zwar
kommen wir jetzt ja Bela zu einer
verbotskultur wie kam es richtig
ausdrücken worüber du heute Abend
sprechen willst auf jeden Fall geht es
wieder um die Grünen ja es geht um die
Grünen vor allen Dingen geht es um den
Landwirtschaft und vor allen Dingen in
diesem Fall um unseren
ernährungsminister um Cem Özdemir der
hat ein neues verboten sich ausgedacht
und heute und dass der anders noch mal
bekräftigt der hat nämlich gesagt es
muss ein verboten gegen
diejenigen die mit zuckerhaltigen
Nahrungsmitteln werben also gegen Cola
gegen McDonald's
natürlich auch gegen Ketchup Hersteller
alle möglichen Zucker drin ist Hamburger
Hersteller
Hintergrund ist und das stimmt die
deutschen Kinder werden zu dick jede
sechste Kind in Deutschland ist
adipositiv also besser bekannt als
Übergewicht nennt man Adipositas das ist
doppelt so viel wie den 90er Jahren und
Fettleibigkeit ist ein echtes Problem
aber woher kommt das und kann man das
wirklich durch Verbote der durch die
werbeindustriebeschneidungen verboten
ein Werbeindustrie verändern ich bin
feste Überzeugung nein es trifft den
falschen willst du mir sollte man in
seinem eigenen Gesetzeswerken nachgucken
denn es gibt ein Gesetz was jetzt 5
Jahre in Kraft ist das ein unglaublichen
Zucker und Dickmacher hier in
Deutschland zulässt in der EU das ist
die sogenannte
hi Fruktose
hfcs my Sirup auf gut deutsch isoglukose
genannt auch das sind Ballaststoffe oder
das sind Zucker Ersatzstoffe die sofort
in den Körper gehen die nicht satt
machen anders als der herkömmliche
Zucker und die bis dahin Jahrzehnte
verboten waren in den USA in den 70er
Jahren gebraucht deswegen die Amerikaner
alles so auseinander jetzt haben wir die
Folgen in Deutschland ich finde es
sollte zurück zu der Regelung diese ISO
Glukose zu verbieten und nicht mit
verbotskultur Werbewirtschaft und andere
hier praktizieren Herr Schubert
Ernährung hat ja auch einen großen
Einfluss auf die Psyche was halten Sie
denn von dem Vorstoß von James mir
also ich bin da gar nicht so dagegen mal
darauf zu gucken wie in unserem Land in
unserer Gesellschaft ernährt wird und
mit welchen mit welchen
gesundheitsfaktoren hier gearbeitet wird
was ich ein bisschen paradox finde ist
dass wir uns die letzten drei Jahre
nicht unbedingt um die Gesundheit der
Menschen die gehört haben ich sehe das
ganzheitlich ich sehe es eben nicht auf
einer reinen somatischen Ebene sondern
ich sehe es so dass ich mich da auch
fragen muss warum essen die Menschen so
viel und warum möchten Sie denn so gerne
zuckerhaltige Dinge essen ja das heißt
ich wäre eher auf der Seite dass ich mir
sagt guck mal doch mal warum essen den
Kinder so viel Schlechtes und warum
wollen Sie denn das und warum sind sie
suchtkrank also die Frage würde ich mir
Stellen einfach eine erweiterten Rahmen
spannen um diese Frage und nicht ähm
wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe
dann möchte jemand etwas tun für die
Gesundheit der Kinder ja und das sehe
ich aber ganzheitlich ich sehe es eben
nicht auf der stofflichen Ebene in Nahr
ungsbestandteile raus zu lassen sondern
ich frag mich eher war aber was treibt
in unserer Gesellschaft Kinder dazu sich
so schlecht zu nehmen so ungesund zu
sein das ist für mich die Frage hören
wie mir das eigentlich begründet was er
hat
durchschnittlich 92 Prozent der
lebensmittelwerbung die Kinder im
Internet und TV wahrnehmen ist für
Produkte wie Fast Food Snacks und
versüßigkeiten deswegen wollen wir ein
kindergerichtete Werbung für
Lebensmittel mit zu viel fettzucker und
Salz gesetzlich einschränken und bei
Kindern hört das Spaß auf auch der
werbespaß meine Damen und Herren ja aber
zuerst geimpft die Kinder zuerst geimpft
mitgehenbasierten Stoffen sorry das ist
verlogen auf Corona kommen wir später
noch zu treffen gehen ist ein gutes
Hinweis weil diese Zuckerersatzstoffe
sind ausgehen manipuliert Mais die
dazugesetzt werden und es ist natürlich
zu kurz gesprungen als du mir gesagt
dass das nur gegen Süßigkeiten und
dergleichen ist bei dieser
Zuckerersatzstoff ISO Glukose ist
mittlerweile in fast allen Lebensmitteln
drin warum bei Zucker süße schmeckt weil
es gleichzeitig den Appetit anregt weil
es nicht sättigt anders als der
herkömmliche Zucker und weil auf diese
Art und Weise nicht auch die Kosten
runter gedrückt werden können also zu
sagen wir müssen das Werbeverbot für
diese Sachen beschränken oder gerade
Verb durchsetzen und und nicht zu gucken
wo ist dieses Zeug noch drin das ist in
Energy Drinks in Brot zum Teil das das
wird das Problem nicht ändern und das
meine ich mit verbotskultur
züncht man etwas über man müsste an den
Kern der Sache gehen und das ist für
einen ernährungsminister viel zu wenig
Hans als Medien Manager was bedeutet es
denn eigentlich für den Standort seit
Standort Deutschland wenn die ganzen
Werte fehlen weil die schalten ja auch
übrigens Werbung in Medien für die
Medien ist es sind Tiefschlag gar keine
Frage und ob man auch darauf
berücksichtigen muss oder nicht ich
meine das ist ein bisschen schwierig für
mich zu beantworten da bin ich sozusagen
[Musik]
aber aber es gibt schon einiges zu sagen
Verbote allein bewirken ja nicht dass es
zurück geht der Konsumer das möchte ja
sagen nicht
so viel gesoffen worden wie in der Zeit
der Prohibition also und das ist ja ein
guter Beweis dafür dass man durch
Verbote nicht als reduzieren kann die
Appelle nutzen offensichtlich nicht dann
weiß ich nicht ob man nicht überschulen
über über eine größere erziehungspakete
ja wirklich die Leute dazu bringen kann
ihren Kindern das zu essen zu geben was
sie auch brauchen natürlich also meine
Tochter sie hat Salat weil sie nur grün
sieht ja wird sie schon wirklich schon
ein ausschlaggeben aber geht's mir
genauso aber aus politischen Gründen
okay
nein aber man muss dann schon wieder
reden und ich glaube ich bin in der
Zwischenzeit noch fünf Kindern also
gesegnet mit viel guten Ratschlägen für
Kinder man kommt schon manchmal durch
man muss ja nur ein bisschen bemühen
deshalb weil in der Super RTL oder dis
oder so wie keine Werbung mehr erscheint
und auf der Plakatwand neben der Schule
nicht mehr für Cola geworden darf also
das wird das eigentlich meine Moderation
übernommen weil du hast ein super
Übergang zu Herr herrles Thema heute
abend
kulturelles Ding ja der das geht den
Staat nichts an was die Leute essen was
will der Stadt denn noch alles verbieten
und wer in der Ernährung nur eine Frage
der Nahrungsaufnahme der richtigen
Mischung der der Nahrungsstoffe sieht
und nicht ein kulturelles Ding der macht
einen einen ganz grandiosen Fehler und
ich glaube dass der letzte mir das
unterstelle ich ihm jetzt einfach mal
dieser grünen Ideologie unterliegt der
den Menschen verbessern will den
Menschen verändern will und da ist eine
Leitkultur und Essen ist Leitkultur es
ist wahrscheinlich das was die leicht
Kultur am meisten ausmacht dann ist die
Leitkultur diesen Leuten im Weg und dann
wollen die nicht dass man sich auf gute
alte deutsche Art
den magenfall schlägt ja also jeder ist
für seine Gesundheit
selbstverantwortlich da brauche ich
nicht einen Herrn Özdemir und überhaupt
keine Bundesrepublik und kein Staat aber
sie gehen ja eigentlich mit den Grünen
noch viel härter ins Gericht und da
kommen wir doch direkt zu ihrer Tee so
heute Abend mit dem Klima genau dasselbe
ist ja also
die Grünen tun alles um den Wohlstand
dieses Landes zu ruinieren und sie sind
das muss ich leider sagen
auch ein Schaden für die Demokratie
die Grünen sie bestimmen die Diskussion
1000 Talkshows alle reden über die
Themen die die Grünen vorschlagen und
wie viel haben die Grünen gewählt im
Bund 14,8 Prozent diese 14,8% Partei
führt uns am nasende durch die Manege
und da ich habe nichts dagegen dass ein
Kinderbuchautor Wirtschaftsminister
werden kann aber er erzählt ja auch
Märchen er erzählt zum Beispiel das
Märchen dass es alles was es gibt auf
dieser auf dieser Erde Autofahren und
heizen und alles nur mit Strom geht und
zwar mit Strom aus Windrädern das ist
das ist einfach eine Lüge das ist ein
Irrtum es gibt nicht genügend Strom für
all das was wir machen will der Strom
ist wahnsinnig teuer diese
extreme
Energiepreissteigerung nimmt den Leuten
das sauer ersparte Geld vom Konto und
dann sollte sich auch noch im
Heizungskeller eine Wärmepumpe
anschaffen die nichts bringt wovon es
nicht genügend gibt abgesehen davon dass
es auch keine Handwerker gibt aber
jedenfalls wird Gas heizen Öl heizen
einfach schlicht und ergreifend verboten
so kann man mit den Menschen mit der
Mehrheit der Menschen nicht umspringen
und ich glaube die Wahl in Berlin die
war möglicherweise ein Kipppunkt wenn
jetzt also die SPD auch kapiert hat dass
man mit diesem ideologischen Grünen
nicht mehr zusammenarbeiten kann dann
müssen sich vielleicht auch mal die
Grünen waren anziehen das wäre zu hoffen
aber die Zustimmungswerte für die Grünen
sind ja nicht im negativen Bereich
eigentlich stehen die Grünen doch ganz
gut da man hat doch fast das Gefühl habe
wenn man ihn gerade auf dem Cover der
Wirtschaftswoche sieht wo er sagt wäre
Deutschland eine Aktie ich würde
investieren macht sich schon warm zum
Kanzler nein nein also da diese Angst
würde ich jetzt nicht haben dann war
warum ist der Habicht so beliebt das ist
ja eine berechtigte und gute Frage ich
glaube
kleinen Kinderbuchautor ist weil er
Märchen erzählt weil man eben zuschauen
kann wie er wunderbar erklären kann was
er nicht versteht ja also dieses dieses
überzeugte nicht wissen das spricht
dafür dass es sich um keine Partei
handelt sondern um eine Bewegung die im
Parlament das ist sozusagen der
parlamentarische Arm einer Bewegung die
was ganz anderes will das was wir in
Sachen Ernährung ja auch sehen den
Menschen verändern ja nicht eine Partei
sein die sich in einer Demokratie darum
kümmert dass man bestimmte Dinge
miteinander aushandelt dass man
Kompromisse schließt es gibt ja den
Klimawandel ja den gibt's aber es gibt
nicht die Klimakatastrophe die einzige
Klimakatastrophe die ich kenne ist die
Klimapolitik der Grünen
den Kopf
nein ich werde mich jetzt nicht sagen
können hier aber ich möchte das
relativieren weil im Endeffekt von der
Ideologie die Sie gerade sprechen da
gibt's auch die Wirtschafts Ideologie
und da gibt's den Kapitalismus das
hatten wir auch schon mal ja
die Grünen haben sich in den 80ern das
haben wir immer noch richtig und und im
Endeffekt muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen
da das ist ein
parlamentarischer Arm ein der Ideologie
ist einer Bewegung naja die
wirtschaftsbehörigen und die
kapitalismushörigen sind doch auch
genauso eigene Partei nicht nein ach
naja dann hat sie es verbreitet ja aber
das gab es schon nur das inzwischen
Wirtschaft warum hat man etwas
grundsätzlich gegen Grünen die Frage ist
wie das eskaliert ist die Grünen und ich
meine das ist eine frustrierte Partei
die sind über Jahrzehnte immer die sind
gestartet in den 80er Jahren ich kann
mich noch erinnern an die anderen boys
and Joseph Beuys der diese Partei
gegründet hat das waren sehr
interessante Ideen wie man Gesellschaft
machen kann und und wie Gesellschaft
sein könnte in Zukunft die haben sich
aufgelehnt gegen einen
Wirtschaftswachstum des monomanisch nach
dem Krieg losgezogen ist einen starken
Staat der den Bürger erklärt was er zu
tun nein überhaupt ich ich glaube
überhaupt nicht anstatt ich glaube viel
eher dass der Bürger dass wir die mehr
Vertrauen geben sollte
das ist vielleicht weniger Parteien
gar nicht für die Grüne Partei Herr
Schubert hat heute nämlich auch schon
erklärt in der Wirtschaftswoche dass man
für einen starken Start auch starke
Eingriffe benötigt das ist ja dann
eigentlich konträr zu dem Bild was sie
haben vom absolut absolut also ich würde
viel mehr Vertrauen an den Bürger haben
was und die Frage stellen was will der
eigentlich und welche welches Leben will
der was für ich plädiere für mehr
Humanisierung für mehr nackt Natur
Bewusstsein der Menschen die wollen das
da bin ich überzeugt davon wenn wir
ihnen Bildung geben wenn wir ihn
kritisches Denken in die Schule gehen
wenn wir nicht diese ganzen Kader
schmieden in die unsere Kinder
hineinkommen wo sie dann linear Denken
in kleinen Ecken und und und Quadraten
wir müssen ihnen die Komplexität wieder
nachbringen von Natur von Kultur von
Mensch sein von Menschlichkeit das ist
eine neue Gesellschaft und die Grünen
haben durchaus sind immer gestartet mit
solchen Ideen aber sind frustriert sind
fertig im Prinzip ist das eine
menschliche Partei so wie alle anderen
Parteien übrigens auch ich sehe
überhaupt nichts anderes in deiner
Parteien Landschaft deswegen stelle ich
das infrage vielleicht brauchen wir gar
nicht mehr vielleicht brauchen wir eine
völlig andere Form von Politik in
Zukunft vielleicht ist das jetzt die
Zeit wo wir jetzt eine riesen
Veränderung haben und der Bürger sollen
wieder entscheiden welche Richtung es
geht wir haben es gesehen die gehen auf
die Straße ein paar davon ja in der
coronazeit wenn sich das nicht bieten
lassen
Moment draußen sie kommen dann schon
damit sich nämlich an und wie
ist ja bekannt aber was ich jetzt sagen
wolltest du ein bisschen zu viel hebe
auf die Grünen ja also so ist es ja
wiederum nicht das ist wirklich ein
Bewusstsein für Klimaveränderung für
klimamaßnahmen gibt das ist schon zu
einem gut Teil den Grünen zu verdanken
und ich bin gegen diese
straßenkleber und so weiter aber
komischerweise diskutiert ganz
Deutschland ganz Mitteleuropa überall
dort wo das passiert plötzlich über die
Klimakrise und was man tun muss also so
ganz verkehrt kann das alles ja wiederum
auch nicht sein ich bin auf der einen
Seite gebe ich ganz zu den gebe ich
gerne zu gegen diese ganzen verboten man
darf nicht fliegen man darf nicht Auto
fahren
man darf eigentlich alles nicht so also
es ist ganz schrecklich Tofu darf man
übrigens auch nicht essen beim tofu ist
ja wieder von Soja das meinte so wieder
wird der Regenwald abgeholt also wird
gar nichts mehr das geht mir in den
Grünen tatsächlich auf die Nerven auf
der anderen Seite als Mahner als
anstoßer die in eine richtige Politik
wie sie nämlich jetzt gerade vorher
gesagt haben in eine klassische Politik
nämlich wie kann ich das Leben besser
bestanden Teilprogramme wenn man aber
die Parteiprogramme Screen dann muss man
ganz klar sagen dass außerhalb der AFD
alle Parteien die Klimaziele erfüllen
oder sogar über erfüllen wollen sie
haben nur andere Wege dahin braucht man
also noch die Grünen als über ein
Parteien schon wenn Klima Mainstream
geworden ist Mainstream im reden ist es
geworden in den Taten ist es natürlich
nicht mehr nur im Internet nicht weil
ich denke nur dass wir in den EU
Beschluss haben gegen
Verbrennungsmotoren aber Deutschland und
Italien die die Fahrzeuge herstellen das
sind natürlich stark dagegen um Gottes
Willen kann man nicht machen gefährdete
Industrie ist ja nur ein Beispiel aber
ein ganz klares Beispiel alle reden über
Politik über grüne Politik aber keiner
tut sie
es gibt ja
den Grünen wirklich ums Klima ginge dann
würde Deutschland zum Beispiel nicht die
selbstgesetzten Klimaziele so massiv
verfehlen wie es der Fall ist und warum
verfehlt Deutschland diese Ziele weil
sie aus aus ideologischen Gründen aus
allem zugleich aussteigen wollen aus der
Kohle und aus der Atomenergie wenn die
Grünen wirklich ans Klima denken würden
dann hätten sie nicht die letzten
Atomkraftwerke auch noch zusperren
lassen sondern hätten neue Brennstäbe
bestellt das ist die Wahrheit das ist
das zeigt er dass den Leuten nicht
zuerst ins klima geht sondern um eine
Gesellschaftsveränderung früher ist das
Klassenkampf heute heißt das
Klimagerechtigkeit es ist dasselbe in
Grün das ist doch mal konkret Mann es
gibt jetzt diesen Gesetzentwurf nicht
nur von den Grünen muss man sagen
sondern auch von der
bundes-wirtschaftsministerium zu sagen
Heizungen ab nächsten Jahr nur noch mit
dem Anteil von 65% erneuert dass der
zuführt wenn man zu einem Heizungsbauer
spricht dass man eine neue Heizung
braucht dann
im nächsten Jahr wenn man eine neue
installieren will also nur noch
Kraftwärmekopplung meistens und mich
wundert jemand wie Lars klingball
SPD-Chef kommt da macht er bella figura
in Kiew aber kommt aus so einer Region
wo diese vielen vielen Einzelhäuser
steht wie sie überall in Deutschland
stehen zum Teil mit Nachbarschaftshilfe
gebaut nicht vor vielen 2030 Jahren und
die müssen alle irgendwann saniert
werden die sollen sich jetzt alle so
eine Wärmepumpe da hinstellen kostet 30
000 €, dann müssen sie so einen eigenen
Technikraum machen kostet auch noch ein
bisschen was wer so eine Kraft
Wärmepumpe hat der braucht noch
zusätzlich Fußbodenheizung ohne geht's
nicht also wenn man ersten Stock hat was
bei solchen kleinen Häuschen notwendig
ist haben sie noch mal 80.000 € diese
investieren sollen und jetzt gibt's eine
EU-Verordnung auch mit Hilfe der Grünen
und
unionskommissionspräsident Ursel Ursula
von der Leyen auf den Weg gebracht wo
ich auch noch dem soll wer soll das
bezahlen und diese Frage würde ich mal
wirklich gerne diskutieren mit einem
führenden Repräsentanten davon
Übergangszeiten das wird wenn es
überhaupt dahin kommt wir geben den
Bedürftigen auch noch Hilfe dazu aber
natürlich nicht in dem Maße von diesen
100.000 von Euro die notwendig sind und
diese Verkennung der Lebenswirklichkeit
nehmen allen klimapolitischen Zielen die
wir alle hier am Tisch natürlich Teilen
in gewisser Weise dass man was tun muss
die Wege sind unterschiedlich das ist
etwas was mir völlig fehlt in der debat
aber das ist ja ganz spannend Bilder du
sprichst ja eigentlich die
Klientelpolitik an der grünen also man
muss sich grün ja leisten können auch
sie würden sich wundern was das kostet
wie teuer es wird aber da frage ich mich
doch ich muss noch einmal auf die
Zustimmungswerte kommen ehrlich weil das
finde ich wirklich ganz spannend die
Grünen scheinen ja immer sehr beliebt zu
sein und die sind ja auch eine sehr
ernste Partei im hohe Zustimmungswerte
wie hoch ist denn da der Einfluss der
Medien
ja riesengroß ich kann mich ja auch über
den Laden indem ich mal ein paar
Jahrzehnte mein Geld verdient habe
sie haben ihn ja vorher schon
ausgesprochen
also ich wundere mich ja nur wie ein
Sender wieder ZDF jetzt sprechen wir nur
vom ZDF weil mich da am besten auskenne
über die Jahrzehnte nach links gerückt
ist
unter Intendanten die alle mit einem
CDU-Parteibuch dahin gekommen sind das
ist natürlich der reine Opportunismus ja
da war 16 Jahre lang Frau Merkel und die
Intendanten nicken und schleichen hinter
Frau Merkel her und machen alles was sie
will die die ergrünung des ZDFs gibt's
ja Zahlen bei der ARD ist nicht anders
60 70% der der Redakteure würden Grünen
wählen die aber die ja grün und das ZDF
sozusagen mit mit Erlaubnis oder sogar
erwünscht von oben zeigt dass da ein
politischer Winter
okay das ist natürlich ist es auch die
gewöhnliche Gefallsucht man glaubt im
Mainstream kriegt man mehr Zuschauer
aber in dahinter steckt natürlich auch
eine Absicht eine
gesellschaftspolitische Absicht der
Sender soll genau wie es der Staat es
will das Volk erziehen und das finde ich
schrecklich wir haben sie geschafft dass
so lange mitzumachen also erstens hatte
ich Ärger ohne Ende ich habe ein Buch
geschrieben das ist die gefallsüchtigen
daraufhin wurde meine meine schon
geplante Verabschiedung gecancelt ich
bin übrigens rausgeflogen als
Studioleiter in Bonn weil ich gegen
diese Art von wiedervereinigungspolitik
eines gewissen Herrn Kohl war also ich
habe ich habe ähm ich habe meinen Anteil
dafür geleistet nicht Strom mit ihnen
förmig genug zu sein aber wir können den
Menschen die nicht
stromlinienförmig sind überhaupt beim
ZDF bestehen
sie werden nur was dort wenn sie
stromlinienförmig sind dadurch jetzt
sich ein paar Leuten Unrecht aber es ist
so es wird ja
schon bei seinem Thema wie viele
Virologen waren einfach nur
stromlinienförmige adapten der
Bundesregierung weil sie dann in die
Talkshows gekommen sind und welche
Experten zu ihrem Thema noch eine Frage
an sehr herrlich es wird jetzt überall
über die Reformation gesprochen das
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunks viele
fördern das sehen sie da Möglichkeiten
wird das passieren oder ist es wieder
eine Blase die debattiert wird
es wird zu sehr übers Geld diskutiert
über die Rundfunkgebühren auf der einen
Seite über die Pensionen der geschafften
Intendanten auf der anderen Seite das
ist zu kurz gesprochen man muss über den
Programm Auftrag reden und man muss wenn
man schon behauptet man sei staatsfern
in Wirklichkeit ist man staatsnah dann
muss man auch die demokratische
Debattenkultur fördern und nicht in
jeder Talkshow dasselbe erzählen sie
sind die Ausnahme der wunderbar ist
natürlich am Rand des apassion nicht
dass sie die Reformkommission die jetzt
ins Leben gerufen wird besteht nur das
Parteipolitiker ja völlig absurd und ist
kein einziger wenn man die Liste also
durchgegangen der jemals mit Fernsehen
was zu tun hatte also das zeigt ja dass
es hier nicht wirklich um Reformen geht
sondern damit man sich einen kleinen
Vorhang bauen muss und den muss man sich
bauen und hinter dem kann man dann
wieder alle verstecken
Kompliment von der Herr ist gehen wir
nämlich jetzt in die Werbung und wir
sind die Ausnahme der stimmt übrigens
sogar
bis gleich
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine Damen und
Herren für 8:15 Uhr wir haben viel
Gesprächsstoff muss das wirklich sein
ich finde diese Debatten unheimlich
wichtig
vielleicht muss ich doch in die Politik
gehen ich möchte dass wir unser Land
nicht ruinieren
ich sag ehrlich gesagt ist das fast
totalitär was sie davon
in der kurzen Pause haben Herr Glückler
und Herr Bruder sich optisch ein
bisschen angepasst das Problem ist nicht
dass wir zu wenig Stadt haben wir haben
zu viel Staaten wenn die alle wegfallen
und wir uns gegenseitig in Berlin Mitte
Cappuccinos verkaufen das funktioniert
nicht dann ist mit Wohlstand aber das
ist alles essen als freiheitsliebender
Mensch würde ich sagen das muss jedem
erlaubt sein
wenn ihr Opfer und Umgebungen von
Menschen in unserem Land fordert dann
müsst ihr bei euch anfangen da muss doch
was machbar sein ich finde aber diese
gesamte Debatte die wir auch fühlen auch
ein bisschen verrückt das ist nicht
aufgearbeitet und das müssen wir noch
machen und das ist leider Gottes auch
ein Punkt mit dem Gerät
[Musik]
wir sind zurück und wir kommen jetzt
direkt zu der These von christian
Schubert einem der ersten Corona
Kritiker der schon corona-maßnahmen
Kritiker war als es nicht irgendwo und
nicht salonfähig war
meine These ist halt mein komplettes
umgehauen wir sind drei Bilder ich bin
völlig überwältigt also meine These ist
letzten Endes dass ich kann mich immer
wieder wiederholen und das habe ich
jetzt drei Jahre lang gemacht und werde
es wahrscheinlich noch die nächsten drei
vier fünf Jahre machen weil ich glaube
jetzt geht es erst richtig los jetzt
geht die Aufarbeitung los und die
Aufarbeitung wird mit Sicherheit nicht
so sein dass man sagt das war es jetzt
wir haben Fehler gemacht und jetzt gehen
wir weiter und machen so weiter wie es
immer war sondern jetzt wird abgerechnet
und Abrechnung heißt für mich nicht nur
das Gerichte sprechen müssen und dass da
jetzt irgendwann mal auch Prozesse
laufen sondern dass wir uns auch ganz
groß und auch hier in der Sendung wird
sie noch mal deutlich ganz groß die
Frage stellen was ist denn eigentlich
Corona gewesen was was ist denn da
wirklich passiert warum ist man mit
Menschen in dieser Form umgegangen wie
man umgegangen ist warum hat man der
natürlichen Immunität keinen Raum
gegeben warum war von Anfang an das
narrativ Killervirus du musst Angst
haben und die letzte Rettung das ist die
Impfung das ist die Technik und das ist
die letzten Endes der industriereibach
also das war ja das ganz große framing
das drei Jahre lang passiert ist und das
war keine Demokratie mehr das war keine
Meinungsfreiheit mehr sondern das war im
Endeffekt entweder du machst das oder du
machst es nicht und wenn du es nicht
machst dann kriegst du richtig Probleme
und sehr sehr viele sind damit in die
Spritze getrieben worden das ist
Missbrauch das ist Dramatisierung
dagegen habe ich mich massiv geäußert
denn damit machen wir Menschen erst
recht krank also was letzten Endes
passiert ist ist Corona ist gleich eine
skandalöse eine skandalöse Zeit sowas
habe ich mir nicht in meinen Künsten
Albträumen ausmalen können sowas Medizin
Medien und Politik fähig sind wenn es
darum geht Menschen zu tyrannisieren zu
foltern und sie krank zu machen und wie
wir ja auch jetzt langsam sehen die
übersterblichkeiten steigen und steigen
und steigen offensichtlich ist da was im
Gange seitdem die Impfung implementiert
wurde ist Übersterblichkeit massiv es
wird noch auf die Sonne geschoben und es
wird noch auf ich weiß nicht
irgendwelche corona-infektionen von
Omegon geschoben wo gar nichts mehr ist
nein es ist die Impfung und das ist ja
jetzt wird es langsam richtig kritisch
also es ist ein Verbrechen an der
Menschheit aber das ist ehrlich gesagt
davor schon gewesen also was mit
Lockdown und Schulschließungen war das
ist sind auch Verbrechen gewesen nur
haben das wenige gesehen
diese Medizin hat versagt und das ist
mein Thema finden sie ist falsch das ist
doch immer geben wird ich finde es eine
Katastrophe also das muss von heute auf
morgen beendet werden hier werden
Menschen in den Schaden getrieben und
zwar bewusst die Zahlen sind alle am
Tisch jetzt kommen sie mit dem Verbot
Rhythmus nee willst da darf man sich gar
nicht mehr impfen lassen wenn sie
glauben sie schädlich oder wie soll ich
das jetzt verstehen
ich sehe den Sinn nicht darin wenn Sie
mir sagen können was der Sinn der
Impfung mit impfen lassen will dann gibt
es das völlig egal was sie dazu
beitragen weil sie sind einer von
wenigen der so spricht wie sie sprechen
es gibt auch Leute die sind für
Impfungen durchaus zugänglich es hat
auch die Infos schaut wieder niemand
bestreiten dass die Impfungen sehr
positive Auswirkungen gehabt haben ob
sie jetzt negative noch dazu haben und
mehr als gefördert kann ich jetzt nicht
entscheiden ich bin keine Mediziner dass
sie aufgetaucht sind
wenn man irgendwas hat und die Grippe
kommt ist immer die Impfung Schulter nur
dass man jetzt genau
also nicht alles vorschreiben ist aber
vorschreiben wie das Licht nicht impfen
lassen darf ich war immer schon dagegen
dass es einen impftrank gibt ja aber
immer dafür dass man sich impfen lassen
wie immer nur dass man sich jetzt doch
Zwang zwängen lassen muss dass man nicht
mehr geimpft werden darf das heute für
ein bisschen Freiheit für alle
Entscheidung
egal ab einem bestimmten Alter will ich
auch kein Thema darin sehen machen Sie
was Sie möchten und wenn Sie meinen dass
sie sich da impfen lassen und meinen
dass ihnen nicht Angst und Panik
eingejagt wurde von Beginn an
zum Panik naja es ist nun mal eine
ziemlich kritische Geschichte haben und
ich weiß dass sie sich jetzt wehren kann
ich mir gut vorstellen ich würde mich
auch werden vor der Wahrheit weil wenn
solche Schäden jetzt da sie hilft dabei
sie sind die Inbegriff der Wahrheit den
haben sie sie allein das ist wirklich
interessant an Mediziner oder oder oder
Menschen aus dem medizinischen Fach für
sich die Wahrheit beanspruchen
der Unterschied zwischen uns beiden
studiert habe ich bin
mediziniert ja das ist richtig aber wir
können uns gerne wir können uns gerne
über die Erkenntnis theoretischen
Irrtümer der Schulmedizin unterhalten
und da kann ich Ihnen gleich sagen da
haben ein riesen Problem ja sie haben
aber wir haben gerade eigentlich ein
Konsens Punkt ohne dass sie beide es
merken und zwar hast du gerade gesagt
kannst das wird die immer Angst und
Bange wenn Mediziner die Wahrheit also
gesehen für sich eine Anspruch aber
genau das ist doch in der
corona-pandemie passiert oder also es
war doch genau das was nur noch
Mediziner und Virologen geredet haben
wenige wurden gehört nicht mehr alle ist
nicht genau das passiert in der Zeit in
ein Ausmaß in einem geringen Ausmaß Jahr
geringen Ausmaß aber trotzdem ich meine
wir haben ja auch einiges verhindert
durch diese Interaktionen sie machen das
Ständer Deutschland der Unrechtsstaat
ist ob der ganzen Welt ist das passiert
Entschuldigung
passiert Deutschland ist nicht ein
Unrechtsstaat deswegen weil sie finden
oder Österreich und ulrichstadt deswegen
weil sie finden ist habe ich jetzt
gesagt Deutschland Österreich
übrigens unter anderem bei der
Bundeswehr ist ja nicht abgeschafft also
Menschen können ja immer noch nicht
komplett frei entscheiden ob sie sich
impfen lassen oder nicht in manchen
Bereichen es gibt auch es gibt auch
Institute für Psychotherapie wo man das
auch immer noch machen muss Fehler du
warst störungssprecher von Gerhard
Schröder die Frage die ich mir stelle
ist jetzt gerade wenn du jetzt Regierung
Sprecher wärst wie würdest du denn
eigentlich agieren und was würdest Du
raten zur Aufarbeitung weil das was
aufgearbeitet werden muss das sieht ja
fast jeder Bürger so absolut als
Regierungssprecher gibst du ja auch
immer die die Linie der Regierung wieder
deswegen ist sie halt die Frage wie frei
ich wäre jetzt hier meine eigene
Meinung da reinzugeben aber was doch
völlig klar ist aus diesen beiden sehr
prägnanten Statements ist dass wir
Aufklärung brauchen und als
Regierungssprecher würde ich diese
Aufklärung auch vorantreiben weil es
kann natürlich sein dass der Schubert
Recht hat es kann auch sein dass sonst
mal recht hat ich weiß es nicht ich war
ausgesetzt in den ganzen Prophezeiungen
von den verstärkten von den Drosten der
sagte dreimal infiziert dreimal
möglichst schwer und dann dreimal
geimpft und dann ist man vielleicht
durch was Corona angeht bzw geschützt
das fand ich schon so aber wenn man das
gesagt hat war das natürlich auch nicht
richtig ich war auch zeitweise auch
richtig für eine Impfpflicht ich habe da
hier schon oft mehr akulpa gesagt habe
gesagt das war falsch aber das habe ich
auch im Nachhinein erst immer offen
gegenüber anderen Meinungen offen war
ich auch aber hier noch mal konkret zu
deiner Frage hier brauchen wir
Aufklärung ich habe auch mal finde auch
wir brauchen eine Untersuchungsausschuss
erklärt was war denn da was lag den vor
welche Erkenntnisse gab es ähm warum hat
man wie agiert und vor allen Dingen wie
ist es heute ähm jetzt bin ich auch
alarmiert wenn ich jetzt höre von einem
verdienten Mediziner der mir sagt das
nutzt alles nichts denke ich was habe
ich denn da drin ne ähm gibt das
vollgeschehen oder was momentan und und
das müssen wir aufklären wirklich weil
so geht es doch ganz vielen Menschen die
sich immer mehr die Frage stellen war
das denn wirklich alles okay Wolfgang
etwas vorgeschlagen er hat ja
vorgeschlagen dass wir jetzt Obduktion
von kürzlich verstorbenen Corona
geimpften vornehmen ja alles was halten
Sie von dem Vorschlag von Wolfgang
also die Aufarbeitung fehlt ja nicht nur
in Sachen Impfung was mich mich haben
zwei Dinge gestört von Anfang an sind
die wirklich gravierenden
Kollateralschäden auch für die
Gesundheit der Leute nicht beachtet
worden das haben Leute keinen Sport mehr
treiben dürfen sind verfettet sind
andere haben psychische Störungen
bekommen weil sie ihren eingesperrt
waren im Lockdown Schulen wurden
geschlossen Kinder wurden traumatisiert
ich bin kein Psychologe aber ich kann
mir das lebhaft das sind nur die
kurzfristig nur die kurzfristigen also
dass die Kollateralschäden überhaupt
nicht in Rechnung gezogen wurden das ist
einfach eine hieß du darfst an allem
sterben nur nicht an Corona ja das ist
die Umdrehung der Mensch ist doch nicht
für ein Gesundheitssystem da sondern das
Gesundheitssystem ist für die Menschen
da und das alles abhängig zu machen von
den freien Plätzen in Intensivstationen
das ist völliger Irrsinn und das zweite
ist das ist langfristige hoch bedenklich
der Wissenschaft wurde großer Schaden
zugefügt denn es wurde behauptet es gibt
die Wahrheit Herr drostens die Wahrheit
die anderen wie er sind die Unwahrheit
das Wissenschaft immer bedeutet Skepsis
ja das ist sozusagen das
eigentümliche von Wissenschaft überhaupt
dass man skeptisch ist dass man Trial
and Error dass man was behauptet das
widerlegt dass man mit den Dingen
arbeitet aber stattdessen wurde bei uns
das zu einer Wahrheit aufgezogen das was
bestimmte Wissenschaftler die sich von
der Regierung haben missbrauchen lassen
würde ich sagen die wurden hoch gehypt
und die anderen wurden auch mit ziemlich
interessanten Mitteln da könnten sie
wahrscheinlich einiges erzählen
geschafft die verloren ihre
Forschungsgelder die verloren zum Teil
ihre Jobs ja das darf man nicht
vergessen und das muss aufgearbeitet und
das ganze hat wie gesagt eine
Entwicklung und am Anfang war ich auch
skeptisch ja und da habe ich Skepsis
geäußert und habe gesagt Mensch schaut
euch das doch mal an da läuft doch was
schief ja
und jetzt sage ich Ihnen jetzt sage ich
Ihnen genauso knallhart wie davor die
anderen geredet haben dass das falsch
war und deswegen finde ich es super gut
die Diplomatie jetzt gelten zu machen
und zu sagen wir setzen uns zusammen
lassen uns das jetzt wirklich mal in
Ruhe bereden und lass mal jede Stimme
gelten wenn ich völlig dabei finde ich
völlig in Ordnung aber ich werde jetzt
laut sein und ich werde weiterhin laut
bleiben ja und ich lasse mir das mit
Sicherheit nicht verbieten ich habe das
vor drei Jahren nicht verbieten lassen
und ich werde mir jetzt nicht verbieten
lassen schon gar nicht hier jemand für
dich dazu sagen ich bin nur immer sehr
skeptisch das wiederhole ich deswegen
bin ich nicht sozusagen die Anti-These
dr Schubert ich möchte nur nicht eine
absolute Wahrheit haben wenn es keine
absolute Wahrheit gibt ja vielleicht
oder in manchenrecht vielleicht auch
nicht ja also es kann man hier nicht
beantworten
die Wahrheit liegt irgendwo wo man sich
vielleicht nachweisen kann deswegen ja
Untersuchungsausschuss wird alles lange
dauert und das wichtigste ist nur am
gesprochen worden ist die Kinder die
eindeutig wissen und das ist das
furchtbarste der ganzen Geschichte weil
das hätte man tatsächlich verhindern
können über die Wirkung der Impfung kann
man streiten ja von mir aus aber das wir
Schulen geschlossen haben und die Kinder
sozusagen ausgesperrt haben die zu Hause
zu Hausarrest verpflichtet haben das ist
natürlich furchtbar gewesen das war
Unsinn und das müssen wir heute zusehen
und ich würde gerne noch was dazu sagen
weil ich bin ja ich möchte nicht so
gelten als jetzt der docmatiker der da
jetzt darüber wischt ich kann das auch
gut verstehen dass man sich jetzt wehrt
gegen diese sogenannte Wahrheit und ich
sag das auch immer wieder in mein
jetzt ja vorsichtig Impfung jetzt als
das grausame Mordinstrument hinzustellen
ja das tun ja so manche meiner Kollegen
auch auf meiner Seite ja und damit
schaffen wir im Endeffekt auch nur Angst
und schaffen im Endeffekt nur wenn dann
das ist Gegenteil von Placebo ist
Nordsee oder das heißt wir setzen
Effekte wo die Menschen Angst bekommen
und dann erst recht krank werden obwohl
die Impfung vielleicht nichts getan hat
und gar nicht so stofflich gefährlich
ist aber es ist eben mehr die Impfung
ist nicht nur Aufarbeitung die eine
sauber Aufarbeitung ist wie gesagt nicht
nur biologisch ist nicht nur ein Stoff
dass ich ihn in eine messenger RNA
sondern es ist eben alles drumherum auch
es ist biopsychosozial aufgeladen es ist
ein Symbol geworden und ich möchte das
Symbol nicht bedienen und andere in
Angst und Schrecken versetzen mit dieser
Impfung das ist letzten Endes nicht das
was ich möchte das insofern tut mir dann
auch leid weil darum geht's nicht dass
das dass wir jetzt sozusagen die andere
Seite plötzlich laut wird und zu laut
wird und zu bedrohlich und bösartig aber
wir haben viel einstecken müssen die
letzten drei Jahre und deswegen
deswegen wird man da auch emotional ich
finde das völlig richtig bleiben sie
laut sie sind immer ein Gewinn für die
Sendung und jetzt kommen wir mit einem
harten Schnitt aber jetzt geht es um
keine Krieg zu Hans mAh und schauen ob
wir da auch so viel Konsens am Tisch
haben
werden wir sehen jetzt also was mich
wirklich aufregt ist wie lange müssen
wir diesen Krieg noch finanzieren wir
Deutsche wir als EU-Bürger wir überall
die gegen diesen brutalen Angriff von
Putin unterstützen wollen
vorausgeschickt ich bin natürlich auch
für die Waffenlieferungen dass die
einzige Möglichkeit derzeit und daher
möchte ich da gar nicht in die Geruch
kommen gut in verstehen was der Teufel
auch alles und ich bin auch für die
Unterstützung der Ukraine in jedem
Bereich im Bus möglich ist aber eines
muss man schon sagen
Experten zwischen 12 und 14 Milliarden
schon in die Ukraine geschickt Waffen
unterstützungsmaterial alles andere auch
noch weiter und was mich aufregt ist
dass es plötzlich heißt oder die ganze
Zeit schon heißt wir dürfen uns aber
nicht einmischen wir dürfen uns nicht
einmischen wie die Ukraine agiert wir
dürfen uns nicht einmischen wann ist
Friedensverhandlungen gibt wir dürfen
uns nicht einmischen
welche territorialen Zugeständnis ist es
möglicherweise gibt wann überhaupt der
Krieg beendet wird wir dürfen nur Zahlen
die deutschen dürfen zahlen zahlen
zahlen die EU darf zahlen zahlen die
Amerikaner auch so kannst doch bitte
nicht sein irgendwo muss demjenigen der
die Möglichkeiten gibt auch ein
zugestehendes gewehrt sein dass er sich
dann mit einbringen kann wann dieser
Krieg beendet wird unter welchen
Bedingungen der beendet wird und das auf
das müssen wir auch Wert liegen gerade
jetzt waren wir so unterstützen wie die
Deutschen zu unterstützen ist dieses ein
Gebot Stunde dass wir das auch sagen
denn wir alle brauchen das Ende des
Krieges und ob es jetzt da geht dass wir
die kriegen auch noch zurückerobern
müssen
da kann man wirklich verschiedene
Meinung sein ich ehrlicherweise bin der
Meinung schauen sobald wie möglich
Frieden zu machen und wenn es irgendwo
der Rituale zugestehen sie geben muss
dann muss man auch dazu bereit sein
müssen wir uns ehrlich machen Herr
Herles ich bin ganz auf der Seite von
Hans war ich glaube nur dass die Kosten
in Euro und Cent der kleinere Teil sind
vor allem auch die Kosten die jetzt
während des Krieges durch
Waffenlieferungen der gleichen anfallen
die Kosten beim Wiederaufbau der Ukraine
werden noch ungleich wird noch mehr viel
viel mehr sein es gibt da auch die
politischen Kosten
ich erwähne nur mal muss die Ukraine
jetzt nur sozusagen als
tapferkeitsprämie in die EU aufgenommen
werden so schnell wie möglich diese
politischen kosten würde ich nicht
bezahlen wollen dann wie schaut's mit
der Akzeptanz in der deutschen
Bevölkerung aus dieser Krieg kann noch
hier das Parteiensystem schrettern ja
wenn man wenn man sieht wie die AFD und
die Sarah Wagen nicht im Moment
harmonieren und Zustimmung bekommen weil
sie gegen diesen gegen diesen Krieg in
der Ukraine sind dann kann das dann kann
das gut sein dass wenn Sie eine Partei
gründet
dass das sowohl die AFD schrettert wie
auch die Linken das kann ja gut sein ja
also sie will es gar nicht beurteilen
aber die die innen und außenpolitischen
Folgen dieses Konflikts in Deutschland
die haben wir noch gar nicht diskutiert
also ich bin ja dafür für ein ein Schuss
Realismus Schuss schlechtes Wort in
diesen einen etwas realistischen Blick
und
der realistische Blick sagt mir dass die
einzigen die entscheiden werden wie das
weitergeht ist auf der einen Seite
natürlich
russlands Präsident Vladimir Putin der
entscheiden wird ob er da weiter Krieg
führt oder nicht die Reaktion des
Westens natürlich auch aber was den
Westen angeht wird dass die USA sein und
wenn die die amerikanische Präsident
oder wäre auch immer möglicherweise
nachfolgt sagt jetzt reicht es oder der
Kongress sagte sie nicht mehr bereit
Unterstützung im Maßen zu geben wie
bisher dann oder der Senat dann wird es
eine andere Gemengelage geben und dann
haben wir Glück wenn wir als Deutsche
gefragt werden oder auch nicht wieder
beim Abzug der Amerikaner aus
Afghanistan der auch über Nacht kam so
kann auch eine solche Entscheid du hier
über Nacht kommen also deswegen sollten
wir uns auf alles entsprechend
vorbereiten nochmal diese Entscheidung
wie es im Endeffekt mit der Ukraine
weitergeht wird bisher von den USA so
beantwortet dass sie die volle
Unterstützung gewährleisten und auch
geben auch materiell noch viel mehr als
wir dass Sie uns dabei auch unterstützen
das gleiche zu tun aber die endgültige
Entscheidung wird in washing getroffen
und irgendwann
wird die Frage der Kosten zu wenig in
der Medienlandschaft debattiert ja wir
sind ein bisschen es gibt einen gewissen
kriegship ja also vor allem in den
Medien
sein
die ganze die ganze Kampagne Deutschland
muss jetzt endlich Panzer liefern ja
wobei sind los sind los ja wenn eine
eine
ehemalige Pfarrerin bei den Grünen und
dann sich frei dass er das endlich
Panzer kommen da wird man schon ein
bisschen schwindelig nicht also das ist
alles nicht so ganz einfach zu ver
und da hat man muss man doch sagen bei
all dem was ein den einen und den
anderen möglicherweise von der SPD oder
von vom Scholz drinnen mag dass er
versucht hat die Europäer und die
Amerikaner bitte auch mit rein zu nehmen
die Verantwortung das muss man in meiner
Ansicht nach hoch anrechnen ja das ist
nicht ein Verzögerung gewesen und sogar
der richtige Weg alle einzubeziehen das
erste und das zweite was jetzt kommen
muss ist und da bin ich also glaube ich
ein bisschen zu optimistisch aber wir
brauchen auch eine Art
geberländerkonferenz ja so etwas wisst
was in anderen Bereichen auch gegeben
hat wo die die Länder die mithelfen dass
die Ukraine die ihre demokratischen
Möglichkeiten bewahrt hat ja die müssen
aber dann auch mitreden können es gibt
ja Vorschläge die übrigens der der Herr
Präsident selenski schon einmal sogar
nicht akzeptiert aber nicht
ausgeschlossen Neutralität und Ukraine
ja nach österreichischen Schweizer
Vorbild das kann sie ja keiner
vorstellen dass die die die die Russen
aufhören bevor nicht klar ist dass das
nicht ein Teil der Natur wird
kann man mehr diskutieren dass die
Neutralität ein Vorbild man kann auch
für Gebiete die dann im unterrussischer
Verwaltungs stehen ein
Mitbestimmungsrecht von beiden Seiten
etablieren und so es gibt genug
Möglichkeiten da braucht man nur bei
Kiesinger nachzulesen
sie denn von dieser Geberkonferenz
ja das ist jetzt sehr spezifisch ich
wollte gerade sagen ich bin weder
Politologe noch Historiker noch
besonders Ukraine Russland
Spezialist genau deswegen Schuber bleibt
bei deinen Leisten und wenn ich bei
meinen Leisten bleibe dann bleibe ich in
der Medizin und in der Medizin ist es so
dass ich einen Zugang habe dass ich mir
sagt wenn ein Symptom ist dann versuche
ich zu verstehen dass sie mir das
Symptome sagen und machst nicht einfach
weg und machst nicht einfach mit
schnellen harten äh mechanistischen
Techniken wächst sondern ich frag
zunächst einmal warum hast du eigentlich
dieses Symptome was hast du eigentlich
diese Erkrankung
und das würde ich mir in einem
übergeordneten sind durchaus auch
insgesamt wünschen denn die Medizin die
die Symptome weg macht neigt dazu dass
sie zu chronifizierungen
stattfinden also die chronischen
Krankheiten würde ich mal sagen
könnten ganz gut auf die Rechnung einer
falschen Medizin gehen ja weil sie immer
die Symptome weg macht und nie fragt
woher kommen die eigentlich und sie kann
es auch nicht beantworten weil sie immer
nur auf die kleinen Stoffe guckt und
niemals auf das große Ganze nie auf
diese gesellschaftlich kulturellen
Faktoren die Menschen krank machen
also und genau da würde ich jetzt auch
aufs große Ganze schauen würde mir
endlich mal die Frage stellen nicht
immer im kleinen herum diskutieren was
läuft denn dort und was läuft denn dort
sind mal die große Frage stellen was ist
denn eigentlich woher kommt es
eigentlich dass die Deutschen erneut
wieder in den Krieg gehen
das wäre für mich so eine Frage nicht ja
es wurde aber schon gesagt wir sind ja
im Krieg mit den Russen ja und ich frage
mich oder warum werden Panzer geliefer
deutschen Seele zu tun die vielleicht
noch traumatisiert ist vielleicht ist es
erster Weltkrieg die Kränkung zweiter
weltkriegt
Amerika hat ja auch das
Wirtschaftswachstum gut geführt nach dem
Krieg ähm hat diesen monomarischen
Trauma Bearbeitung der deutschen schön
mit äh erlaufen lassen und da frage ich
mich schon ich meine jetzt könnte es ja
durchaus wieder diese alten Sachen sein
die vielleicht endlich mal aufgearbeitet
gehören ähm das sind für mich so Fragen
die ich mir stelle als Arzt ja also
einfach mal das übergeordnete angucken
und schauen wo sind die Ursachen für das
wo wir jetzt drin sind geht's hier
vielleicht um eine falsche westliche
Kultur ist vielleicht hier der
Kapitalismus am Ende und wird
entsprechend beantwortet ich weiß es
nicht aber das würde mich interessieren
ja das war jetzt ein sehr großer Exkurs
damit schließen wir die Runde sie sehen
bei Debatten haben immer andere
Meinungen und das ist auch gut so und
morgen ist der Weltfrauentag und wir
haben heute mal ganz Ideologie frei mit
vier Männern den begonnen tschüss
schönen Abend noch bis morgen dafür
lassen wir dich hochleben
[Musik]